I got to show you that video Oh ass
video man oh boy yeah yeah I watched as
I watched a last video with Ariana but
we got a mansion video and that was I
didn't realize these two were going to
be like so strongly connected otherwise
what it's showing you that one first
concept yeah Adam more context would
have made some stuff seems maybe you
know a more beneficial when you're
watching it because that one was just
like a vlog hyper Rocco Rock I thought I
did it but it kept seeming like it was
building up to a sketch then it didn't
it was just like Oh another fun it was
like a crazy hyper edited raka raka
style vlog and here they infused that
blog style with a little bit more film
style stuff like the guy with the
experiments in the garage or the back
house base they hinted at that last time
it didn't show who was there and that
weird interrogation scene this is how
the interrogation see the top of this
guy getting beat up say you got to get
us to like a certain amount of like I
don't know if they're doing some type of
vlog series now where there's it's like
a storyline they have connected with
what's going on with it because they
keep intercutting between vlog and
sketch and I'm wondering is this all
this get or is it half log half sketch
yeah yeah like did you guys get a new
place and you're making stuff in the
meantime while you get settled in or is
this going to build into some kind of
crazy narrative we just enjoy yeah
because it seems like it's kind of
building into that is the first ones
doing okay yeah they got a new place so
they're going to do a vlog about it now
they're continuing that they're picking
up with the blue guy in the beginning I
like whether you see the behind the
scenes of what they're working on that
was really cool yeah I'm very curious to
see even more than I would like to see
more vlogs of rack of records behind the
scenes stuff sometimes that feel like
too much that can ruin some of the magic
behind what they're doing a lot of the
curiosity whether you're going into like
the real estate agent guy I don't know
if that was a real real estate no no no
like that is the case there to me to him
he kept looking like a little bit more
sleazy at the he kept having more fun
his shirt was completely hooked and like
only halfway button
a candy bar halfway through they had the
character living in the back house now
yeah so I feel like it's building to
some kind of narrative I'm curious to
see what it's building to like if that
one guy going to have just electric
powers forever now are they revamping
what Rocko rakha is at on a house racket
you know so I'm wondering is this a
house record thing a separate segment I
don't know if they have released some
statement on one of their social media
sites or not about what it specifically
this is but I'm enjoying it because even
the vlog format
I like how they edit the blocks up like
a crazy rack Iraq and edited style
bringing it back to it yes I almost feel
like if I'm not a huge fan blog so like
adding their craziness to of yeah it
almost makes the mystique that much
bigger because now I don't know what
these dudes are like yeah like now I'm
like it's just life with you guys just
crazy I'm like is this must be the
loudest place to live gotta be just kind
of okay with the fact someone might jump
on you at all times you know everywhere
that jackass true that makes more than
pranks yeah and they're really natural
like on camera so that adds to the
mystery to me like I don't know what to
make of this it's so kinetic that I
can't help but yeah sucked up into it
and enjoy it you know and I agree on the
BTS stuff too I think it works really
nice here because it's like out of
context sort of it's just in a big
warehouse we don't know what video it's
for yeah yeah and they're you know the
first time you know the one dude just
made a finger gun and someone got
actually shot you know like an actual
squib went off actually copy let's
breath and it means graves I never
registered those can be painful yeah
yeah I mean it's a little explosion
still there they like all the big pitch
yeah yeah like a pop on you I don't know
I'm really enjoying it I'm loving what
these guys are always like raka raka how
great they are every time you show me
one of these I want to see more yeah and
I love the kinetic energy of this whole
style of vlog series are doing I'm
wondering like even when it feels like
it's just a blog is it yeah like is this
is like you know are we going to do the
world with you guys you like it out like
I said it's gonna breach harder and
harder into fantasy every time we check
back in or something
well hey okay well I mean before they
have another one coming out so before
that one comes out I gotta show you the
first one
yeah person was already on it who's
never seen a rack of rack or video house
which doesn't truly represent what their
videos are actually like most of the
time you know I would like to probably
watch the next one we use as you've seen
plenty of record record yeah I know that
I know the racket you know the racket I
know the rack I want to spend more time
in the house of rakha I don't know if I
could hang out with you guys yeah that's
what I wanted let me maybe when there
are many cameras maybe they're very
mellow
yeah very sweet very soft slogan or
something but yeah this makes it look
like just like their life is this yeah
and I can't tell if that's a really
funny joke or that's just them yeah cuz
R all we know this could all just be one
giant sketch yeah maybe they just said
hey you know let's make a vlog but let's
do it our style and every time we
furnish our new house we'll make it
scheduling yeah yeah because that's like
like the foosball thing kind of became
just a sketch within a sketch you know
oh yeah or even guy with the powers
including that stuff and it has elements
releasing and jumping in and out of like
letter but back in there like watching
transformers a last night yeah yeah but
you know better
oh yeah and while we're here what's a
shout out for Jeff bears and Peterson
but we've hung out with this guy one of
our perks on if you pledge a certain
amount to be part of our exclusive
Google Hangouts or private sessions
Jeff's been in a few of them and man is
that guy usually the star of those hands
that yes let me get on to hang out with
Jeff he has that radio voice he doesn't
and he's got the vulgarity he's got the
drunken attitude he's got he's got that
like well like lived in quality I don't
give a [ __ ] dude it
yeah he's like generally of good spirits
but also not giving a [ __ ] it seems like
he's just had one of every life
experience I don't know if bearskins his
real middle name or not but I would
believe it after getting to know the
sky hill to bear with his bare hand I
would war it's generally the Jeff's
personality I would believe that yes sir
I've been off on a bender I'll tell you
III fought a bear I skimmed it and I
ain't in meat because I was suck I was
stuck in the middle of you sounds like a
[ __ ] my exploit yeah alright guys well
yeah make sure to watch this video in
full-screen format because this is well
worth it yeah you can subscribe to rack
a rakha subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell like we
said earlier debt John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and you could
check out all our exclusive personal
rewards over at patreon